but right now we turn to the phone line
senior fantasy football expert I keep
forgetting when he wants to be called
what does he want to be called analyst
senior fantasy football analyst of
DIRECTV's fantasy zone he's so good he
still hasn't gotten to win in the
Allison change League and we are about
to make him Owen six perhaps like the
knee he's like the New York Giants
he's the Ben McAdoo of fantasy football
Michael Rapaport how do you like that
intro Michael excuse me it's senior
fantasy football analyst aren't I
playing you this week you are you're
about to be on six yeah oh no I'm gonna
I'm gonna I told I spoken on that lead
before the Jerry Cantrell Allison Wi-Fi
during the draft come on forget all that
and forget all that oh I'm gonna I'm
gonna drag you I'm gonna make an example
of the of you this weekend which I love
you I'm gonna do it out of respect but
I'm also gonna make you an example I'm
gonna have you nude and scraped up
Monday morning I'm all the dragon like
your good work we're gonna drag you
through your clothes and Monday you're
gonna come in a little bruised it's
gonna be all right and then you're gonna
acknowledge how I piecemeal together
this victory against you okay
yes again against you and your team just
and and it's gonna be it's gonna be
rough and rugged I'm gonna keep I'm
gonna give this league and this team
extra attention and we're gonna we're
gonna piece together this win okay
although out of all the people that you
have that I'm concerned about
and that's Brady against the Jets
DeMarco Murray against Indianapolis
Pierre garçon against the 40 and against
his old team we'd love to tear up Adam
Thielen terrelle pryor
okay all those all those folks Texans
against Cleveland that should be a nice
field day with Kevin Hogan star I am
concerned of Jerick McKinnon I think
Minnesota is gonna start using him in
the Dalvin cook role against Green Bay
and you got him you picked him up that
was a good pickup I'll give you I gave
him that one thank you oh did we lose
him right there I'm here okay good can
you hear me I can't hear you yeah I'm
here you you know you could say it's a
good pickup and I could say thank you
but I don't need the acknowledgement of
it being a good pickup every pick I make
your own size Oh
Michael it I'm telling you Monday you're
gonna come in bruised battered and torn
some I'm sorry let's give the people
let's give some the people something
portable okay give me give me give me
give me somebody who's a who your who's
a lock who we should believe the hype
you always give us to believe the hype
don't believe hot I want to believe the
hide from you for a week six alright
Michael terrelle pryor as you mentioned
this is the week he's gonna break out
okay he's he's basically playing a new
position obviously he's on a new team
Washington is moving forward this is
going to be the weekend that he gets his
numbers and that you get what you
expected from terrelle pryor number one
believe the hype also as you mentioned
and I feel like you you read my notes
book Carson versus old team no Josh
Norman he's going to ball out he's been
balling you know he's got a attitude
he's tough he's rugged he's rugged verse
the Redskins Pierre Garcon Golden Tate
versus Saint he's the play in that game
for the Detroit Lions and CJ Anderson
verse did totally disorganized
dismantled New York Giants offense and
the New York Giants defense CJ Anderson
is going to put up numbers this week I'm
not going to give you any reasons I'm
not gonna even you expert explanation
I'm a senior fantasy football analyst I
just win okay I just win those are for
people who believe the hype if you want
it if you want it if you want to listen
to me here don't do what you want to do
now this is a no-brainer and Big Mike
Evans is one of my favorite players in
the NFL said the Patrick Peterson is
probably the most offensive defensive
fantasy football player in the league do
not believe the hype on big Mike Evans
it's not happening this week he's gonna
get locked down you know he might score
a touchdown you might get to catch it
and there's no feelings of fantasy it's
not personal and Ben Roethlisberger I am
so disappointed in you and this is not
going to be the bounce-back week versus
Kansas City Chiefs
the Jacksonville last week almost sent
you in the retirement
literally almost sent you in retirement
I'm ashamed of ben roethlisberger I'm
ashamed that that after the game he said
during the sit the fifth game of the
season I might not have it anymore well
then maybe we don't have your paychecks
anymore like sorry I don't want to hear
any of that you might not have it
anymore though no feelings and no crying
and football okay so Ben Roethlisberger
is not bouncing back this week he's a
big concern of mine that's it there you
go I give you six names you did those
are money pics believe the hype don't
believe the hype yeah and that's it well
before I let you go Michael I mean we
are using the photograph of you on our
on our graphics here your hair is
slicked back and with the number of wins
you have and our fantasy I'm telling you
you do have a very Ben McAdoo quality
you know and and congratulations to that
because I mean at some point you'll
break out - I'm not concerned rich I'm
not concerned I could say this um
greatness baguettes greatness yes and I
will be putting my best foot forward to
bodyslam uses like Jimmy like the late
like like like Jimmy Superfly Snuka
right off the top rope I'm coming down
and and and I'm not doing it like you
know you know timid man style I'm doing
it like I'm landing this lamp I'm just
telling you that's what's gonna and I do
with level respect or it's because I
love and respect you but I'm doing what
I got to do alright alright we'll look
forward to seeing you on on fantasy zone
channel 704 on Direct TV this weekend
with the rest of the cast you take care
of yourself Michael okay all Sunday will
be there were given out the best
information and I'll be I'll be checking
with you next week and probably like
Thursday or Friday and hopefully the
bruises and the swollen will have gone
down okay it'll be great and you know I
work blue on the text chain it'll be
great this weekend I'll be all right no
problem
okay problematic excellent that's at
Michael Rapaport on Twitter there we go
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy